welcome to this meeting of labour
district council cabinet i'm councillor
clive arthy deputy leader of baby
district council
firstly i have to remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down or if you are exempt from
doing so and you use the hand sanitizer
and wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
finally we will be using e-voting for
this meeting on the modern.gov app so
please good members make sure they are
logged in and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
at this meeting that it will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you are making a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film or photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
can i please move to the agenda
item one
apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from councillor ward and
councillor dawson
okay
item two
sorry
thank you
yeah thank you mr chairman councillor
sean dawson has also given her apologies
but she may turn up late
okay
i think you did mention her apologies
didn't you i certainly did but that's
fine that's noted
okay
thank you
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interests by
members
anybody
none
item three
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 4th of october 2021.
you have those in your papers
are there any points regarding accuracy
no we can have a proposal please we
accept the minutes council busby
seconder
councilman crawl thank you
the vote
you ready
yes the vote is now in progress
councilman vasey are you having trouble
voting
may i take your vote uh verbally please
chair that is eight votes for that's
unanimous
okay thank you
move on to item four
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme none received
item five questions by councillors none
received
we're whizzing through item six matters
referred by the overview and scrutiny or
joint audit and standards committees
there are no matters referred okay
item seven forthcoming decisions list
comments anybody
no comments
okay we can note that
move on to
item eight
the infrastructure funding statement for
baber april 2020
to march 2021.
[Music]
um i ought to tell you that cabinet has
agreed previously that this
infrastructure funding statement and
future statements
will be circulated to all members and
published on the council's website in
due course
therefore this item is not for
presentation to the cabinet today
however
um
there is
there is something that i was going to
say
um with regard to
the report as i said it's asking you to
note the contents um and that it will be
sent to the government
um and it's it's basically a statement
of fact for the period april 2020 to
march 2021.
um so as i've said the proposal is
that it's the last time we actually have
to formally bring this
to
cabinet
so you've got a recommendation on your
papers today
at
3.1 and 3.2
that you note the report
and that you agree the publication
on the council's website
and that i propose
can i have a second to please
i'm councillor barrett thank you
any comments anybody
councillor barrett
um yeah
the only thing i would say when you get
a report of that size i do find it quite
difficult to get to the detail when it's
just on
i mean i'd have read through it but it
is quite difficult with sort of quite a
weighty report with quite a lot of
detail on it
i do find these
tricky to just get it on the laptop
because it doesn't fit a whole page
either
it's just an observation i thought the
report was very very thorough um i'm
rather pleased
you know we are spending the money to
good causes within the community which
is what it's designed for um and
hopefully the parishes will take use of
that that money that they're getting so
yeah it's good to see and i think it's
good that the public see that this is
going out so
yeah well done clyde for producing that
thanks well i didn't actually produce it
of course yeah but if you're dating and
you mentioned the amount of information
in it obviously as cabinet members a lot
of this information would have come
before you during the course of the year
as things have been reported to you this
is a
statement for the 12 months and a lot of
what's in there you will already be
aware of
councillor busby
well this is where i usually make my
three-word
um complaint capless and mary
tom
and we're going to have a meeting on it
i think aren't we
so yeah
thank you
um sorry counselor busby i didn't quite
get the point you were trying to make it
capable mary's significant
infrastructure requirements are excluded
from this report
and have been in every preceding report
um
but we do have significant requirements
and we are collecting significant sill
it's just a case of how we get ourselves
listed onto this report
indeed i think today one one million
three hundred and seventeen thousand
pounds has been collected
um
for capable mary
um and there's about seven hundred and
seventy thousand
um due as well so it's quite a
considerable amount
yeah i think we've had about two pound
fifty out i think
okay thanks councilman crawl
i think i think the issue is under the
seal infrastructure system we use is you
need to prepare a bid and there has to
be a bid that's oven ready and although
it's undoubtable that communities have
needs i know my own does
um preparing that bid
and bringing it to the point where it's
oven ready
is not as easy as just you know
putting some figures down on a piece of
paper you really do have to do the
grafts behind it
thanks and regarding capless mary in
particular we will be engaging with the
community at cable st mary um to try and
um get from them their views of what the
infrastructure needs of the community
are
council halt
yeah following on from cagles and mary
is another a parish in my ward glenswood
which is um
in desperate need of infrastructure
improvements uh otherwise there could be
no growth
so sort of the other side of the
spectrum really compared to capable
where it's got a lot of growth and needs
infrastructure but glenside on the other
hand is is being stifled by a lack of
infrastructure and cannot grow
so that's something that uh i think uh
tom perhaps we could have a discussion
about at some point because there's no
money going to come in to help it
because it can't grow
so i think that's something that needs
to be picked up
okay tom did you want to comment on that
um just very quickly yes i understand
the the the real constraint in glensburg
is the primary school capacity and the
inability of that to to expand but
certainly i think it'd be
useful for us to have a conversation
i'll get something in the diary
thank you councillor osborne thank you
mr chairman yeah i think picking up on
some of the points that have been raised
by other cabinet members council of ours
one about members of the public being
informed of all the good work that's
being done
and being funded by seal i think it's
really really important to get that
message out there so i do hope that they
read the report
or find the bits that they do need to
read i don't know if we can summarize it
in any way but that message is
absolutely clear to get out there on
another point i also think it's clear we
get the message out
that these town and parish councils that
money's there for them to bid for and
they need to start bidding there must be
something in all the other parishes and
towns that haven't bid that they need to
bid for so i think there again it's
a message that we need to get out some
of the responsibility is with the
district councillors to get that message
out to their own wards but also baber as
a whole to get that message out so
yeah and we will be doing that we'll be
engaging further with parish councils to
explain to them um the situation with
regard to their own neighborhood seal
which will be paid to them or has been
paid to them
and also
to reinforce the message
with regard to community bids
okay
any other comments
no
it's been proposed and
seconded
are you ready to take the vote
okay
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
[Applause]
that is eight votes for chair that's
unanimous
thank you
okay
move on to item nine
which is the transfer of open space land
to build mary parish council
and great waldenfield parish council and
i'd like to invite the cabinet member
for assets and investments to introduce
the report
thank you this report seeks approval to
transfer land at pikes marsh viewers and
green acre great walding field to the
respective parish councils
transfer of these small parcels of land
would enable the parish councils to have
control and through local management
improve the economic social or
environmental well-being of these areas
responsibility and maintenance will be
at a more local level empowering the
local community to deliver the services
they want and need whilst removing any
cost liability from the district council
the district council owns many community
assets and in many cases the parish
councils are often best placed to manage
and respond to the needs and
opportunities of their local communities
the transfers will each be for the
princely sum of one pound but there will
be a covenant put on the land to ensure
that it remains as open space
thank you
thank you very much are you proposing
the recommendations i certainly am i
guess okay it's your paper i'm sure you
are okay i'll happily second that myself
one of them
happens to be in my ward as well
which is green acre in great waldenfield
and i'm wholly supportive of the
transfer to the parish council
the area has developed into a much
appreciated public space and the parish
council have already been involved in
managing that to provide real benefit to
the local community
they have access to funds including
neighbourhood seal which we were just
talking about
to provide the improvements and ongoing
maintenance and our best place to
further enhance the area and secure its
future for the residents of the village
members
any questions
on the report
council osborne
thank you mr chairman can i ask this
point while we're in questions how much
weight the covenant will have to keep it
as open space
this place
yes uh sarah cameron corporate manager
for strategic property um it's as strong
a restrictive covenant as we can it will
run with the title and um if the parish
councils were to
want to change the use of the land at
any point they would have to come to us
and negotiate with us but we're under no
obligation to to remove that government
okay thank you councillor
just in case i mean if they did come is
there a betterment clause in there
and that hasn't been included in the
heads of terms to date but that is
something that we can negotiate in might
be worth putting in just as a safeguard
well i think it should be in there yeah
i'm not sure if it actually forms an
amendment or whether it's just a
suggestion with regard to that's
agreeing to the transfer but we agreed
to the transfer we're not getting into
the legal text are we right okay that's
fair enough okay thank you
any other comments anybody questions
debate
somebody say something you must be
either supportive or or yes councillor
osborne thank you mr chairman yeah i
fully support this um only a few years
ago we were discussing the importance of
encouraging our town and parish councils
to take ownership of their own land and
i think this supports that approach in
every detail so i fully support it
and i hope that other talent parish
councils will be coming forward with the
same suggestions
thank you council malvisi
thank you chair um
i see that pike's marsh has already got
play equipment on there so will baber
hand over
the play equipment in a fit and proper
fashion
you know so that it's not condemned the
minute
the ink is still wet
yes yes it's in good condition at
present having been handed over to us
through the section 186 process but uh
yes it will be handed over in good
condition and would that policy continue
with other applications um i think
that's something that we'll have to
discuss with our public realm colleagues
moving forward on a case-by-case basis
yeah
yeah i think there's also equipment on
the area of land in great weldenfield
but i think that's actually owned by the
parish council
they've
come to us every time they've wanted to
put something there and we've always
given them permission
council hold
yeah i think this shows a
good approach by the district council
working with the parishes
i think each individual
plot of land as and when it should come
forward
is treated on its own merits
but um for these two parcels of land it
seems a very sensible approach
um and i'm sure both parishes will
welcome it and the residents will
benefit from it so yeah very good news
some years ago we started talking about
localism
this is localism in action
any other comments members
no
okay well in that case we can um
we can head towards the voting it has
it's been proposed and seconded has it i
seconded it it must have been proposed
and seconded that's great
okay did you want to conduct the vote
yes
the vote is now in progress on your app
is it
yes it is
chair that is eight votes for that's
unanimous
okay
that has completed our meeting that must
be a record time i have to apologize for
the slightly late start
sorry
councilman crawl a record i can recall
attending and not as a cabinet member a
meeting that took 15 minutes
right yeah so i do apologize for
starting a little bit late that was
because um i had a bit of a rush to get
here
but we're all done
the next meeting is scheduled for monday
the 6th of december 2021
at 2 o'clock thank you very much indeed
meeting closed
you